[Music]
jessica is in Minneapolis hi Jessica how
are you hey Dave I'm doing great how are
you better than I deserve what's up in
your world I'm coming up with a kind of
an oral slash integrity issue I need to
know when bankruptcy is the only option
well I've been through it not proud of
it and I should hope my worst enemy so I
kind of put it in the in the category of
divorce it's something you would do
after you had tried every single other
thing to fix it and it can't be fixed
right every possible thing and then I'd
wait a little while right so let's talk
through your situation to see if I can
help you how much debt do you have I
have 130,000
in vehicle debt $54,000 in credit card
debt 30,000 incredible debt no mortgage
no savings no 401k 110,000 a years our
annual income for our family of three
and my husband I are 34 38 okay what is
$130,000 vehicle you got a tractor
trailer we we do we actually only have a
an SUV a diesel truck and then we have a
fifth wheel we were in the oil and gas
industry and so we actually traveled
with that fifth wheel we do no longer
travel so now it's it's and I pay for it
every month okay what if you sold all of
their vehicles that's my concern I guess
I would love to sell the one vehicle
that sold them all it's a leased vehicle
to lease the other the the fifth wheel
and the truck I would love to get rid of
I'm just upside down on them so bad I
don't even know how to go about
offloading them but that doesn't make
you bankrupt even if you don't even if
they repo'd them you're not bankrupt
yeah that's my concern I just don't I
feel like not only my situation yeah you
feel trapped so let's
let's work through some types okay
worst-case scenario rather than
bankruptcy just quit paying payments LEM
come get all of it
okay and then deal with a deal with the
repo you got the money to do that cut up
your credit cards as soon as you get off
the phone all of them don't even keep
one you suck at handling credit cards
would you agree with me yes all right
good and get on a written budget every
dollar with your husband and you to sit
down look at that now let's start
working on getting out of these cars I'm
coming up on a break I'm gonna hold you
through cuz I've been as scared and
stuck as you are and I want to help you
get out of this so you can you hang with
me for a second all right we are talking
to Jessica in Minneapolis who is in a
mess 130,000 dollars worth of cars
trucks and 5th wheelers $54,000 in
credit card debt 30,000 a medical 110
thousand dollar income wants to know if
she's bankrupt and we said no but she
isn't a mess legitimately so first thing
is we're gonna cut up all the credit
cards and get on a written budget on
every dollar calm get the app loaded so
that every dollar is behaving husband
and wife are both in agreement that
there is no life in this house in terms
of lifestyle we're beans and rice rice
and beans scorched earth until we get
this mess cleaned up is that okay with
you Jessica
absolutely good okay now let's walk
through these cars for a second car
number one is leased what is it and when
did you buy it
it's a 2016 Lincoln MKX nice car okay
and so you leased it in 2016 yeah at the
time the sticker on it was 52 52 all
right almost like I've looked at them
before okay and let's see 16 17 18 how
long have you had the lease we had it
since December of 2016 so we've been
paying on it for a little over a year
okay 13 months out of how many months
how long is the lease 36 months okay all
right perfect
so here and I assume the lease is with
Ford Motor Lincoln Lincoln finance right
mm-hmm so
here's what you know you call them and
you ask them for the early buyout
because you want to get the title in
your hand okay you do not ask for
anything other than that the early
buyout this is like getting the payoff
on a traditional loan that does not
include all the future interest it's
what's the principal balance today do
you follow me yeah okay I'm gonna tell
you that that is going to be for example
purposes we're gonna call that $43,000
no I mean your pet your lease payments
or how much 450 okay no it's gonna be
$45,000 okay
give or take all right maybe a couple
thousand bucks but somewhere around it
we're gonna use that as our example okay
then you jump on Kelly Blue Book calm
mm-hmm and you look up what the car is
worth if you sell it to an individual
not wholesale to a dealer okay because
we're not desperate yet but we're
getting there fast okay and let's say
that you look that car up and it's worth
room 38 probably not far off
okay which means your $7000 in the hole
in our example do you follow me yeah now
we need $7,000 and we can get on this
car so where we gonna get $7,000 are you
late on any of this stuff yet no
everything 100% paid on time
dadgum your credit sterling okay so you
might run down to the credit union and
borrow $8,000 to get a thousand dollar
car bit of a step down and $7,000 to
cover this whole do that and get that
loan arranged but don't take the loan
until you get a buyer when you get a
buyer you give Lincoln 40 you get the
buyer to give you a check for 38 you get
seven from the credit union and you send
Lincoln a check for 45 and they send the
title to your buyer great and you're out
of that one okay now that's gonna be a
lot of work and a lot of hassle and
that's gonna take you several months but
that's better than just throwing the
keys into the snow right all right now
so
second car is a truck big diesel truck
right yes in 2014 Ford f250 Super Duty
that's a beast okay and what is owed on
that puppy 51,000 dollars on it okay and
have you looked up the value on it yet
yeah it's about maybe 32 on a good day
is that a trade-in value or a private
sale value that's not very low private
sale private sale value actually wow you
took a bath on that puppy yeah it has a
little over a hundred thousand miles on
it oh you run the value out okay what's
the who's got the loan I have a trio
credit union Bingbing
okay mr. credit union manager I'm now
sitting in your office looking across
the desk at you mr. credit union manager
you have a thirty two thousand dollar
car loan and attached to that you have a
19 thousand dollar unsecured loan
because if you have a fifty-one thousand
dollar loan on a 32 thousand dollar
asset 19 of it is unsecured would you
agree with me Jessica correct yeah and
we've just got to convince mr. credit
union manager of these actual facts in
which case he agrees that I'm trying to
avoid bankruptcy
I talked to Dave Ramsey on the air he
said to work with you and pay you the
difference and put that on an unsecured
note and you let us have the title when
we get a buyer mm-hmm in the same
routine so you're going to end up with a
seven thousand dollar note somewhere or
an eight thousand dollar note you're
going to end up with a 19 thousand
dollar note for the difference over at
the credit union and all of these holes
that you're in are due to dumb moves
that you made I've done Dumber moves
when I do stupid things and it costs me
money I call that stupid tax you're
gonna write some checks for stupid tax
over the next few years yeah okay now
those too so I just took fifty I just
took ninety six thousand dollars and I
turned it into 25
so far amazing yes sir we're done I
think I think you're gonna make it it's
gonna be a pain in the butt but I think
you're right you're not gonna die from
this okay same thing with a stupid
trailer 30 grand on it the trailer
actually is a large fifth wheel and so I
owe 65 on it then your numbers don't add
up
51 and 45 and 65 do not equal 130
Wow the Lincoln is a lease so I only put
the lease amount due on the Lincoln oh
okay you owe 65 on the fifth wheeler
right same routine what do you what's
the balance I mean yeah what's the value
good Lord nothing about about 56,000 but
only if I only if I sell it outright and
I try to go to a dealer it's about
30,000 won that's right and again who
has the loan the same credit union that
has the truck perfect let's just
increase this routine as a matter of
fact I might sit down with mr. credit
union and go dude
I don't want to hand you the keys for
all this stuff but I'm about to and you
get the same the 7000 lot alone to get
you out of the lease with the same redit
Union out of the package euphony
he gives you an unsecured loan for eight
or ten thousand dollars in addition to
what your upside down on the trailer in
the truck to get you a couple of beater
cars to drive and to get you out of all
three of these vehicles mister otherwise
mr. credit unions getting ready to lose
all this money anyway because you're
getting around handing the keys and if
you file bankruptcy he's lost all this
money all the unsecured portions gone to
zero right that's his best case scenario
if you go bankrupt and you know you only
go in threatening bankruptcy and like
playing all cowboy or something okay you
go and you know go I really made a huge
mistake we're stuck I thought I was
bankrupt but Dave Ramsey says I can come
in here and he says that it's better for
you and better for me if we work this
out would you help me and let's look at
this together and that's not the
conversation sounds
okay and you go in there humble not
threatening hmm
because but you say stuff like I don't
really I don't want to file bankruptcy
help me not have to file bankruptcy
because you're gonna lose like your
shirt on this and then it's gonna ruin
our lives and we don't want to do that
we want to do the right thing and work
this out but we can't keep doing it the
way we're doing it so you gotta let us
sign notes for the difference on these
things right help me out here brother
you know and this is how you convert the
tone of your conversation sounds and and
then we're down to these unsecured notes
the credit cards in the medical and we
just get on a plan and work like crazy
people and live on nothing and start to
work the debt snowball and pay off your
smallest to your largest and work your
way through this let's see we're going
to end up with 19 and been doing it it's
gonna take you three years you can do it
you can do it in three years you're not
but you're not bankrupt but it's gonna
be a tough tough three years and you can
just shut your stuff of all this if they
won't do anything and you toss on the
keys deal with them deal with them and
repo you probably still not bankrupt
probably still work through it and I
want you guys to go through Financial
Peace University I'm gonna pay for it
because I've been scared like you guys
are I know how it feels I don't want to
walk with you so hold on James this card
not James Kelly's gonna pick up James
cut to ban get you the Financial Peace
University signed off this is the Dave
Ramsey show